today's video is brought to you by
athletic greens and its wonderful daily
blend of vitamins and minerals ag-1 by
athletic greens is a comprehensive
all-in-one greens powder engineered to
fill the nutritional gaps in your diet
and support your body's nutritional
needs across four pillars of health gut
health immune support energy and
recovery it's packed with 75 vitamins
and minerals and whole food sourced
ingredients combining the perfect amount
of micronutrients absorption and taste
to jumpstart your daily routine you'll
be hard-pressed to find a more
comprehensive powder
supplement on the market right now look
as you guys know i'm not exactly a
fitness youtuber but i do like to eat
right take care of myself an ag-1 is
that comprehensive nutritional
supplement that i know is going to
account for any holes that i might have
in my diet just one scoop into the water
bottle in the morning shake it all up
take a hit off it easy does it
[Music]
and you know you're good for the day
either with my coffee in the morning i
feel it kind of
sustains my energy a little bit not sure
if that's just placebo or uh
either way it's all rather good for you
isn't it plus age one is gluten free
dairy free paleo vegan keto low allergen
and low calorie less than one gram of
sugar per serving look it's the perfect
dietary support regimen so if this
sounds like the supplement that you've
been looking for then grab your own
immunity bottle that's one year of
vitamin d hold on
looks like this little dropper that you
add to it plus
five of these individual travel packs so
if you go away for the weekend boom just
grab a couple of those and you can keep
up with your routine brilliant these are
all for free by the way with your first
purchase go to athleticgreens.com
forward slash biographics again
year split vitamin d the travel packs at
athletic greens dot com forward slash
biographics link below and now today's
video
in 1976 a nightmare afflicted central
africa from the depths of the lush humid
forests an invisible killer struck out
for civilization carried by animals it
passed like a ghost into humans who took
it with them back to their families but
this was no evil spirits no creature of
folklore no it was something much worse
the ebola virus twin outbreaks that year
were humanity's first contact with one
of the world's most terrifying diseases
hundreds died in agonized misery wracked
by fevers in some cases
bleeding from every orifice but while
these villagers were the first known
humans to die of ebola they certainly
would not be the last in the decades
since that poisonous summer ebola has
reared its ugly head again and again
modern-day drc south sudan gabon uganda
nigeria guinea sierra leone liberia and
more have all been afflicted with the
worst epidemic in 2014 killing 11 000
people yet even as scores succumbed to
this plague humanity was mounting a
fight back that would eventually lead to
a breakthrough a tale of both horror and
hope this is the story of ebola the
disease of nightmares
of all the ways mother nature wants you
dead perhaps no method is quite as
terrifying as ebola one of three known
phyla viruses it belongs to the same
family as the similarly icky albeit less
deadly marburg virus like marburg its
natural home is the dense forest of
central africa where it's thought to
circulate widely among bats and just
like marburg catching it will put you on
a non-stop express ride to a very yucky
hell at some point between 2 and 21 days
after you've been exposed you'll be hit
with a sudden feeling of illness one
that seems to come out of nowhere at
first this will be merely unpleasant
you'll suffer sore throat fever joint
pain headache and a general feeling of
weakness unless you've previously been
in contact with an ebola patient you'll
probably assume you're suffering from a
nasty bout of flu well hold on to that
feeling because when the full force of
ebola really hits you'll find yourself
praying for the good old days of
influenza not long after your faux flu
symptoms develop a wave of vomiting and
diarrhea will overcome you but this is
still just the beginning deep inside
your body the real horrors of the virus
will be starting to reveal themselves
ebola you see affects the way your blood
clots this leads to something called
disseminated intravascular coagulation
of antiwar saying that it makes your
goddamn blood vessels leak and since all
that blood has to go somewhere we get to
ebola's freakiest stage when blood
starts seeping out of your orifices now
this symptom doesn't affect every victim
but it happens often enough that it
seared itself on popular memory
with good reason the worst afflicted
suffer blood coming from their mouths
ears eyes noses and rectums add to this
rash and hiccups and you'll spend your
last hours on earth as a horrific mess
before finally dying of multiple organ
failure and make no mistake dying is
almost certainly what you'll do right
now there are four known subtypes of
ebola that affect humans plus two resin
and membali that only sicken on human
primates the four that you have to worry
about one type thai forest has only ever
infected a single person a researcher
who caught it while examining a dead
chimpanzee the other three though are
where things get really freaky whether
you catch the zanya sudan or buddha bug
yod subtypes the highest survival rate
you can expect is a mere 60 and this is
the best case scenario catch zaire ebola
virus and there's a 90 chance of death
it's simply one of the deadliest viruses
known to man luckily though the chances
of you ever being exposed to this killer
are unbelievably remote while viruses
like flu and covered 19 spread on tiny
droplets produced by coughing or
sneezing ebola doesn't work that way nor
can you catch it by shaking hands with
or sitting near an asymptomatic person
the most common way to pick up the virus
is by coming into contact with bodily
fluids a serious problem for healthcare
workers but less so for say youtubers
yay other routes of transmission include
sharing dirty needles touching soiled
clothing or traditional funerary rites
that involve contact with the body oh
and you can also catch it by having
unprotected sex with the guy who
recovered from ebola for some gross
reason virus remains in men's semen for
ages still these relatively difficult
routes of transmission mean ebola rarely
crops up outside of remote villages and
since it's a disease of the forest most
epidemics can be traced back to forest
workers who come into contact with
infected animals or to people who eat
contaminated bush meat and even if you
catch it it's mostly treatable since
2020 the fda has licensed two types of
ebola medicine for the zaire subtitle
cutting the mortality rate by 90 percent
yet it wasn't always this way just a
handful of years ago ebola wasn't just a
terrifying virus when it first emerged
it was also a death sentence
most scientists today are pretty sure
that ebola existed long before the first
documented cases circulating among wild
animals in the congo's impenetrable
forests and there it might have stayed
had population growth not led to people
slowly encroaching on those same
rainforests the first known human case
was a cotton factory storekeeper in what
is now south sudan tiny place known as
nazara on june 27th 1976 the man came
down with an unknown illness dying a
mere five days later in no time at all
the contagion was sweeping the factory
felling his co-workers before spreading
to a nearby hospital thought to have
been caused by bats roosting in the
factory the outbreak eventually infected
284 people killing 151 but while this is
the earliest known ebola outbreak on
record it wasn't the one that gave the
virus its name that honor would go to a
near simultaneous epidemic some 700
kilometers away in yambuku zaire now the
democratic republic of the congo that
september local teacher mabala laquila
fell ill and died with virus early
similar to the one that had killed so
many in sudan that summer for those
living in laquila's tight-knit
missionary community his death and its
hideous nature were a source of shock
but that shock quickly mutated
into sheer terror over the coming days
the local hospital was flooded with
patients people paralyzed with pain
people bleeding from their pores soon
318 people were sick with 280 of them
dying the catholic mission itself was
devastated in small surrounding villages
the majority of the population was wiped
out faced with this unknown threat
zaya's dictator placed the entire region
under martial law it was this chaos that
led to the virus being named after a
river mabala laquila had visited before
he became ill it would only be later
that scientists discovered the ebola
river had nothing to do with the illness
or why it was spreading so fast no it
was the mission itself that was
infecting so many people issued with
only five syringes a day for 300
patients the local nuns had taken it
upon themselves to start reusing needles
needles that now carry the deadly virus
to new victims eventually congolese
doctor jean-jacques mayembe and belgium
microbiologist peter pio managed to
figure out what was going on and halt
the spread but not before they'd done
something groundbreaking it was from
their samples that the new virus was
isolated the cause of the nightmare
illness was finally identified the last
victim died on november 5th leaving
behind a devastated region yet this
wouldn't be the end of ebola just three
years later the virus resurfaced in
nazara in the same cotton factory as
before this time infecting 33 people and
killing 22 not that it was the exact
same virus that had killed mabala aquila
although it was long assumed that the
nazara and yambuku outbreaks came from
the same source scientists later
discovered they were two distinctive
subtypes of ebola zaire and sudan but
whether they were the same or different
they both subsequently vanished yeah
they just vanished totally at least in
humans after the smaller 1979 outbreak
there would be no more documented cases
of ebola in humans for 15 years when it
did return in 1994 it would initially be
just a single scientist infected while
examining a dead chimpanzee in ivory
coast's thai forest sadly though this
pause would turn out to be exactly that
a pause a chance for the virus to gather
its breath and prepare
for the next onslaught because as you
already know ebola did not vanish in
1979 eventually it would come back and
when it did
it'd be deadlier than ever
even during its post-1979 pause ebola
continued to weigh heavily on humanity's
mind if you're old enough you might
remember the scare around infected
monkeys at a lab in reston virginia
where a new strain of ebola was
discovered that fell primates in
eye-watering numbers thankfully the rest
and subtype turned out to cause no
symptoms in the handful of humans it
infected a fact that should go down as
one of history's great near-misses still
the scare kept the virus in the
headlines and nor was it the only ebola
warrior in the uk scientist portend down
managed to accidentally prick himself
with the contaminated needle while he
survived two scientists who managed the
same screw-up in russia weren't so lucky
both went to die horrible and tragic
deaths still as 1994 dawned it was on a
world in which ebola was just an exotic
word one tinged with fear but still
abstract enough to be comfortable
unfortunately for humanity things were
about to get decidedly
uncomfortable at the end of 1994
disturbing reports started filtering
into the city of makoko inkabon of
primates out in the forests dying
horribly not long after that the first
human patients arrived at the hospital
men who'd been hunting for gold near
where the apes had been found and were
now experiencing the tell-tale symptoms
of ebola although its return was a shock
the gabon outbreak was contained rapidly
a mere 52 people fell ill with only 31
dying far fewer than either of the 1976
flare-ups but gabon's brush with death
was only the warm-up act the headline
would be taking place to the south and
east in one of the viruses original
homes zaire the 1995 outbreak in the
town of kikwit was the resurgence that
virologists had feared after a charcoal
maker came back from the forest feeling
ill ebola exploded across the region
multiple hospitals became clearing
houses for the disease in kikwit and
surrounding villages swats of people
fell ill desperate to stop the spread
the government blocked the road to
kinshasa by the time the epidemic was
brought under control panic had swept
the world and 254 people were dead and
this time there would be no vast gap
between outbreaks the rest of the 1990s
and into the 2000s saw a kaleidoscope of
ebola flare up some big some small until
barely a year could go by without a
bunch of villagers dying horribly as the
outbreaks increased they also spread to
new countries like uganda and the
republic of the congo and the number of
infected also started creeping up the
2000 to 2001 uganda outbreak saw the
number of patients in a single event
climb over 400 for the first time
meanwhile yet another variant emerged
this time around the town of bundy bugio
taking the total number of human
affecting ebola viruses up to four by
the end of the first decade of the 21st
century over a thousand people were
known to have died of ebola a low number
compared to say gobert 19 but high
enough to represent a real worry still
this worry did come with a silver lining
even as new records were broken for
infections in a single outbreak the
numbers themselves remain manageable bad
as it was for those of the epicenter
even 425 cases in one go wasn't
apocalyptically bad and while ebola
refused to go away there was some hope
that we could learn to live with it
after all we thought we understood it
that it was a disease of the forests and
villages that it was scary as heck but
could easily be stopped before it got
out of hand
how wrong we were just like all those
magazines in 2016 preparing madam
president front covers humanity in this
era had badly misjudged things come 2014
ebola would go from freaky thing it's
fun to read about on cracked.com to the
bringer of west africa's local
apocalypse
[Music]
by any arctic the death of a mill omono
was a gut-wrenching tragedy just two
years old emil passed away on december
28 2013 in guinea a country of around 13
million people on the west african coast
many many kilometers away from congo's
tropical forests sad as this lamil's
death was though it was just a preview
of what would soon become one of the
biggest tragedies in the region's
history the boy you see hadn't just died
young he'd died of ebola the first time
the disease claimed a life in west
africa and it certainly wouldn't be the
last within weeks of emil's death half
of his family had also died killed by a
virus as swift as it was brutal after
that came the mourners then the
healthcare workers before long the death
toll in guinea was creeping up it would
take the authorities until march 2014 to
recognize the deaths for what they were
part of a new ebola epidemic one
striking a country that had never
experienced it before yet it wouldn't
stop at just guinea by the end of the
month the virus was cropping up in the
country's crowded capital the first time
ebola had ever attacked an urban setting
but it would be another funeral that
made the disease start spreading like
blood red wildfire given guinea's
fragile health system many of the
viruses victims turned instead to faith
healers the most famous of whom was
sierra leone's mendenhall when she too
died of ebola the funeral was massive
people came from all over guinea sierra
leone and liberia to pay their respects
respect that as tradition dictated
involved contact with her body sadly
that was just what the virus needed
mendenhall's funeral was a super
spreader event sending dozens back to
their home countries with ebola already
working its dark magic in their
bloodstreams by may both sierra leone
and liberia announced they were fighting
outbreaks with things in sierra leone
being particularly acute the hospital in
the country's second city kanema was
soon overrun and with hygiene practices
not being followed ebola soon began to
spread among patients workers and
visitors alike as west africa's death
toll swept into the thousands cases
began appearing in nigeria and senegal
followed a few months later by mali by
the end of 2014 9 000 west africans have
been killed by the rampaging virus
thousands and thousands more than during
even the deadliest previous outbreak and
as the death toll skyrocketed so too did
the conspiracy theories yep apparently
pre-covert humanity was just as awful as
its pandemic counterparts and not
believing stupid bull from social media
in guinea for instance a conspiracy
theory that ebola was a smoke screen for
white people to kill west africans led
to eight aid workers being murdered in
the cities meanwhile the rumor that
patients were taken into hospitals to
have their organs harvested resulted in
people escaping isolation wards thus
further spreading the disease it was a
tidal wave of disinformation a tsunami
of horse droppings that only caused the
epidemic to get ever worse yet it wasn't
just confined to west africa even as the
disease consumed entire towns in guinea
an equally deranged form of panic was
taking root thousands of kilometers away
yep it's time we turned our attention to
the global capital of social media
freakouts
america
in september 2014 thomas eric duncan
stepped off a plane in texas unaware of
the blind terror he'd soon be trailing
in his wake duncan you see was a
liberian national and he hadn't stepped
off the plane alone oh no inside him was
a stowaway a member of the file of iris
family picked up in his home country and
when he finally began showing symptoms
he'd kick off a health scare unseen in
america since the 2001 anthrax attacks
the media freak out following the
hospitalization and subsequent gruesome
death of duncan was
off the charts shortly before british
nurse william booley had likewise
unwittingly brought the virus into
britain well around the same time
another aid worker tested positive in
spain for a brief period the news was
full of maps and charts showing ominous
red dots in places like texas new york
and britain places where new cases had
been confirmed millions convinced
themselves that it would soon be
sweeping across america yet thanks to
better funded health systems and
different burial traditions ebola never
took root there there was no wave in
europe beyond the infection of two
nurses carrying the duncan there was no
community transmission in the u.s but
that was cold comfort for west africa as
2015 began the virus continued to chart
its destructive path eventually 28 000
cases would be confirmed yet even as
this catastrophe unfolded another more
hopeful tale was quietly being written
the story of how we at last began to
master this awful illness the search for
an ebola vaccine began way back in
mid-1980s fittingly in marburg germany
where one of ebola's cousins had first
been detected in humans there heinz
feldman was working on filoviruses when
he learned of an astounding breakthrough
over in yale a scientist named john jack
rose had figured out how to use a kind
of livestock virus known as vsv as a
delivery system for vaccines intrigued
feldman began dabbling with vsb himself
seeing if he couldn't get it to carry
the ebola glycoprotein at this stage the
work was mostly theoretical yet it
clearly stayed with feldman in the early
2000s he ran a test whereby he used vsv
to infect a bunch of mice with ebola's
glycoprotein before exposing them and a
control group to the virus itself unlike
their unfortunate counterparts the vsb
infected rodents all survived and so
began the long and torturous path
towards an ebola vaccine there was the
2005 study by tom geissberg which
repeated the mice experiments in
primates and again revealed that vsv
deliveries seemed to offer protection
and there was the incident in 2009 when
a german researcher accidentally pricked
himself with ebola affected needle and
was quickly given the experimental
vaccine as a precaution her survival
showed that it was safe to use in humans
but the biggest boost came with the 2014
outbreak prior to the tragedy in west
africa no government or pharma company
had wanted to finance an ebola vaccine
the disease
just cropped up too rarely and infected
too few people to make it profitable but
as the world watched the carnage
unfolding in guinea sierra leone and
liberia that calculation changed at the
end of 2014 the company merck finally
agreed to run a trial and that was how
teams from medicine science francieres
came to be on the ground in guinea in
early 2015 offering the experimental
vaccine to anyone who needed it to be
clear by this time the epidemic was
already winding down improved sanitation
and a widespread understanding that
traditional burials were contributing to
the viruses spread had slowed its pace
there's no suggesting the vaccine ended
the outbreak what it did do though was
provide solid proof in a real world
setting that the damn thing really
worked in july 2015 respected journal
the lancet published the study's
findings taking humankind one giant step
closer to a world without ebola but
while this was truly an incredible
breakthrough it came too late for many
in west africa as the epidemic receded
it left behind the sort of death toll
usually reserved for a war over 11 000
people had died while many of the 17 000
survivors were left suffering a myriad
of complications which today we might
call long ebola in short it had been a
catastrophe a humanitarian disaster on a
grand and depressing scale it was also
thankfully perhaps the last major ebola
epidemic the world will ever face with
the vaccine now proven to be both safe
and effective the path has been laid for
a rapid response to further outbreaks
when the virus reared its head again
just four years later in drc teams were
on the ground armed with shots within
just eight days over a quarter of a
million people were vaccinated and while
over 2000 people still died the virus
stalled out with far fewer fatalities
than in 2014. nor was the vaccine the
only leap forward in 2019 a similar
real-world study was conducted with
experimental treatments using monoclonal
antibodies during an outbreak of zaire
ebola virus astonishingly researchers
showed they raised survival rates to a
staggering 90 percent by the end of 2020
the fda had finally approved two ebola
treatments and one vaccine with a
separate vaccine targeting the sudan sub
type already under development in
england and that's where things
regarding ebola stand today on the
threshold of perhaps a grey new era one
in which this disease of nightmares will
soon be reduced to a treatable if
unpleasant illness it's a change that
can't come soon enough since it first
reared its ugly head in 1976 ebola has
been responsible for tens of thousands
of deaths nearly all of them on the
african continent in this it has been
helped by autocratic leaders and corrupt
governments the kind that pour so little
money into health care that overcrowded
hospitals become places that spread the
disease rather than contain it and
honestly this might be a bowler's real
tragedy since the late 1970s we've known
that the best way to stop ebola is
simple using gloves isolating patients
and giving healthcare workers proper
protective equipment yet thanks to
poverty and neglect it's been able to
crop up time and time again to kill
those already living on the margins the
fight humanity has waged against ebola
might be one we're on the verge of
winning but until we tackle the root
causes the factors that drove it to
become so deadly in 2014 will sadly
remain in place ready and waiting for
the next nightmare virus to arise
so i hope you enjoyed today's video
before you leave let me tell you about a
new channel that i'm doing called into
the shadows so maybe the world isn't
dark enough for you well good news it
absolutely is and if you'd like to know
more about the horrible things that
humans have been doing to each other
since well time immemorial well please
check out that new channel into the
shadows from land mines to penal
colonies to horrific diseases if it's
horrific we cover it check it out
through the link in the description
below again it's called into the shadows
and thank you for watching